the World Health Organization has been
um attempting to finalize alterations to
their pandemic preparedness plan that
involve absolutely
tyrannical uh surrender of sovereignty
that they have been plotting to um allow
anything at all to be declared a public
health emergency and then on the basis
that something is a public health
emergency to erode our ability to
discuss things in public to mandate
treatments including gene therapy it's a
really frightening set of Provisions y
but here's the important part I have
been getting uh murmur that actually we
are having an effect and that the um the
pandemic preparedness measures which
were hurdling towards ratification in uh
I believe May of this year are actually
faltering this stuff was designed not to
be read we were supposed to all think it
was too bureaucratic CO's in the past
not paying attention and because several
people including uh maybe most
especially Merill nass have been
cracking these changes and calling
attention uh of other covid dissidents
to it we've picked up this story uh
anyway it is now faltering so Zack will
you show that um Guardian article so
here we're showing the guardian on I
believe the
22nd um of January Global pandemic
agreement at risk of falling apart who
warns and then I'm going to keep reading
if it's big enough for me to see from
here can you scroll a little bit Yeah
would you do
that it says plans for a global pandemic
preparedness agreement risk falling
apart Amid wrangling and disinformation
according to the chief of the World
Health Organization who has warned that
future Generations quote may not forgive
us now that is an interesting claim that
come back to shaken by the pandemic The
Who 194 member states decided more than
two years ago to stop start negotiating
an international Accord aimed at
ensuring countries are better equipped
to deal with the next Health catastrophe
or to prevent it all together or to
prevent it all together interesting the
plan was to steal Seal Seal the
agreement at the 2024 World Health
assembly the who's decision-making body
which convenes on the 27th of May
however
Tedros uh whose second two names are
tougher to pronounce says the who's
director General uh the who's director
General said the momentum had been
slowed down by entrenched positions and
a torrent of fake News lies and
conspiracy theories so he doesn't call
us out by name but he certainly mentions
our effect um he warned that if nobody
was prepared to seize the initiative uh
or give ground the whole project was at
risk of going
nowhere okay uh tedras told the who's
Executive Board in Geneva on Monday time
is very short and there are several
outstanding issues that remain to be
resolved etc etc so anyway the point is
we are not so the paragraph that I see
tedro said claims that the Accord would
seed sovereignty to the who or give it
the power to impose lockdowns and
vaccine mandates were quote completely
false we spent a fair bit of time I went
I went through um one of those documents
um very very in a very detailed way and
we talked about what was in it and um
what he said there is completely false
well I so Tucker surprised me by showing
me Tedros claiming this on video that
there was no surrender of sovereignty
and I then went back later and listened
carefully to what Tedros said and it's
very interesting his claim was based on
the fact that we live in countries in
which we are represented and that they
are surrendering your sovereignty oh we
talked about this actually we talked
about this on our last live stream I
think like you've already you live in a
representative democracy we've just
taken over the Reigns your
representatives have seed your
sovereignty to to us right but here's
the crazy part Tedros is now saying well
the thing is in danger of faltering
because of lies and misinformation When
In that clip what he said was you have
to get your representatives not to do
this if you don't want your sovereignty
uh eroded that basically your
representatives are your mechanism for
deciding what you do and don't want to
do and now he's complaining about the
fact that that's what we've done right
we have exerted pressure on our
Representatives they're not interested
in signing up for this that is our
sovereignty and um he doesn't think it's
legitimate so anyway it's a fascinating
topic but really my overarching point in
showing that is we are supposed to part
of the fifth generation ation Warfare
stuff is that we are supposed to feel
powerless we're not powerless we're
talking about a small number of people
raising the alarm amongst large
audiences using the tools of the
internet
using Twitter and Rumble and the various
tools that we are allowed to use to
spread the word and the fact is people
do care they are paying attention and we
have to keep fighting now I just one
last
caution when you get on the scale and
you see a number that you like that's
not a sign that you should start eating
more and not exercise that's a sign that
you should keep going right so the point
is this is good news if we we have to
fully derail that treaty right we cannot
say oh phew it's over for one thing
these people don't take no for an answer
and if they can't do it through the
World Health Organization they'll do it
some other way so we have to be vigilant
and when we get Goliath back on his
heels we have to keep going so that's
the message here is we are having
success we are not supposed to know that
but having discovered that we have power
we need to exert it and drive uh the
tyrants back into their cave
[Music]
MH